jason we're gonna bring you on now uh
are you there yeah can you hear me okay
pop dude first of all
in the spaceport uniform
yeah i got approval to come on air so uh
thank you for having me i'm honored
let's start first cause you got the
uniform on uh space force what the hell
is space force like the first time i
heard this i was like oh that's a
hilarious internet meme like no and then
literally we have space force like what
is space force
yeah uh space force is a new military
branch dedicated to
organizing training and equipping
military forces in support of and
presented to
the new designated geographic combatant
command called space
or us spacecom so
think it does the same thing that like
you would expect the army to do for
different combatant commands but for
space and so we've legally defined
everything above i think it's like a
hundred
thousand kilometers or something there's
some threshold where that is formally
now a combatant command okay so when i
think of space force and this idea of we
need to like patrol and protect the
space right uh from a uh a military
standpoint are we worried about other
countries are we worried about aliens
are we not worried about anything but we
just feel like hey maybe we should go
stake our you know like kind of like a
dog when it goes outside like is my area
like like how do we think about this
so right now the main concern is other
countries okay not aliens okay
disappointing but okay
[Laughter]
and is this more of like um uh
satellite like uh almost um
i would think of it as like control
right so like hey there's there's space
around earth and if people are able to
position satellites or other types of
technology in certain areas that could
be a national security threat or
something else is that like a general
uh idea of what what you focus on or
early space force focuses on
that's one part of it okay so something
that was cool about when we set up space
force is we formally declared a new
delta whose role is to
protect and defend on orbit from orbit
which is
sounds awesome yeah but that's not the
only that's not the only thing that
space force does a lot of our weapon
systems that we use on the ground
terrestrially
depend heavily on
space-based capabilities so like i
imagine when you were downrange you
probably used
gps a lot you probably used
satellite communications a lot i know
that
if there's ever like a motor attack well
not a motor attack but like a rocket
attack on people who are downrange we've
got assets in space you can see that and
they tip and cue and they warn the
people at the forward operating bases to
take cover give them eight more minutes
than they would have had otherwise so
the majority of our space systems
are dedicated to the support of
terrestrial combat
um
but
the issue is now we're getting into a
situation and you can read about it and
listen to our higher ranking generals
than me
where
you know the china-russia's fans out
there have learned that a good way to
disrupt terrestrial combat is to
point the gun at the satellite in space
and so that starts to beg the question
okay well now we have to figure out how
to create
satellite systems that are more
defendable
that um
and then if necessary to punch back
okay so last question i have around
space force and we'll get to uh things
that you probably want to spend more
time talking about uh but just out of
personal curiosity if i think of uh
humvees on the battlefield you know
years and years ago uh most of them had
no weapon system on it and then over
time we realized like hey one there are
targets they need to be able to defend
themselves and two actually they have
some mobility to it they have certain
aspects uh that they can provide better
weapon systems and and uh kind of be an
offensive tool as well maybe we should
put some weapon systems on top of these
home fees are we gonna see satellites
with like missiles attached to it or
some sort of like anti-missile satellite
technology like is that where this ends
up even it's 50 years away
so
i mean i don't know what the future will
be but
space presents a whole bunch of
different challenges
the main problem with kinetic power
projection in space is
something called kessler syndrome where
if you create a bunch of shrapnel or
debris using like a missile then you
could cause way more damage permanently
than you
would ever want to so we just had russia
shoot down a satellite and immediately
we had astronauts taking cover
in the iss because there's a whole bunch
more debris
orbiting
the earth now so
there's a lot of different ways that you
can project power and defend or do
offense in space kinetic
is one of them but
i hope
that would never be used in space okay
hold on you got to run me back here for
a second russia shot down a satellite
and the astronauts the iss had to take
cover
yeah happened like a couple weeks ago
you're saying that like i like that's
like a a thing that's gonna happen
regularly now like should we be worried
about that i mean china's done it
right the united states did it a while
ago but we were we made sure that the
the fragmentation would come back down
to earth not would stay in orbit right
so this brings up a whole bunch of new
questions on what is responsible
behavior in space
um and so a good way to think about like
a war that extends into space is
that would be a war without winners that
is very similar to a nuclear war right
so that really the job of space force
right now is to do whatever we can to
deter the fight from ever going into
orbit
because of how devastating that would be
to civilization as a whole
and so to that end there's a whole bunch
of other ways that you can project power
without causing kessler syndrome right
you can use
jamming methods you can do use directed
energy weapons
you know you can you can cause
non-permanent damage but still have a
similar effect
if that makes sense yeah uh it's
incredible to think about um where we
are now and how sophisticated it could
get uh given it seems pretty primitive
at the moment but like that's some scary
[ __ ] um one more thing before we move on
i just thought of another one
so what's cool about creating a
combatant command for space is that now
you have a combatant commander who can
tell
our friends at the army or the navy or
the air force
hey can you come help me out so another
way that you could like project power
or disable a harmful enemy satellite is
just to have your army friends blow up
the control
for that right that's somewhere on the
ground right or have your air force
friends drop a bomb on the control
station so these are the things that you
have to think about even though maybe
the pointy end
of the spear might be in space you can
still cause
the effect that you want terrestrially
all right now i got another stupid
question uh if you blow up the control
center let's say you drop a bomb from
the air force uh satellite just uh float
away or like what happens to the
satellite it's like uh i don't know
where where to go i don't have any
controller like i just sit up there in
orbit and spin around or what goes on
yeah probably i i would imagine that's
what would happen yeah all right
space is wild i i invested in a company
uh varda um that uh is doing like space
factories
and as i was learning more and more
about this whole idea i was like wait a
minute you're telling me you want to go
do things up in space that's like
cheaper faster you know lighter whatever
and then bring it back and they're like
yes and i was like that sounds insane
i'm in uh so like you know space warfare
is even crazier um all right talk to me
about uh bitcoin and kind of your
journey i think a lot of people i was
saying before you came on uh you're on
linkedin you're
freaking killing people on linkedin and
then you came over to twitter i see you
laughing so i know that you you're
probably giggling to yourself while
you're just firing off on people on
linkedin uh when did you first come
across bitcoin what attracted you to it
just kind of walk me through uh when you
first discovered it
i remember being
this is so
typical of what you would expect someone
like me to say i remember being at a
star wars trivia night in a bar talking
to my friend and my friend had bought
bitcoin and he was explaining it to me
it was like 2013 2014. it was it was 300
i don't know when it was it was 300 at
the time
and i thought it was cool because like
as a kid when i
you know was playing video games i was a
huge nerd there would be in-game
currencies
and i remember like trying to convince
my parents
like they need to give me money so that
i can go buy some in-game currency so
that my character could be stronger
right
and so when i first heard about it i was
like oh that's pretty sweet it's like an
in-game currency but forget for reality
but i didn't think that it would work
because i thought you know
the government would stop it like a lot
of people still do today and so you know
my story i think will be similar to a
lot of other people's story where we
just have to live with the regret of
thinking that way and discounting it
over time after learning and reading
more i eventually
realized okay there's something to this
and it's extremely resilient to attack
maybe i should start to buy some yeah
and so talk to me today about how you
see bitcoin one of the things that i
think you've done a fantastic job
talking about is the network itself and
how to think about it essentially
defending uh the folks who hold bitcoin
etc and given the fact that uh you know
we could sit here and talk probably for
hours about defending space or defending
other types of uh attacks you've got a
very interesting perspective so just
maybe walk us through how you see the
bitcoin network as like a defense
mechanism
yeah so i guess
this deserves some clarification up
front
when you say something is a weapon
system or something as a defense system
some people like jump automatically to
thinking you're describing a gun or
something like that
but
a lot of things are defense systems and
or weapon systems that you wouldn't
intuitively think about so for example
the romans created
stone roads between ports right that was
that was created by the roman legion it
was a defense system so that they could
get to you know defend their ports
easier thresherly
or for example like this is a good
example why do you think we have gps
if i ask you that
why
right yeah why do we have gps to
understand where we are and where we're
going
right so
to have precision navigation
right and also to have precision timing
because every gps satellite has an
atomic clock in it correct
okay so why do you think we actually
built gps
so everyone's on the same page in terms
of time
right so the reason why we built gps
we're getting a quiz
damn f minus go ahead
when when sputnik was first launched it
was sending out a radio signal and we
had americans that were measuring that
signal
and they realized the scientists
realized that you could do time distance
of of arrival off of a satellite which
is cool because then you could
triangulate your position relative to
the satellite
and so for 20 something years 25 years
the scientists kept on arguing it would
be really beneficial to humanity if we
created a giant constellation of signal
emitting satellites that would allow
anyone any anywhere in the world to be
able to triangulate their position
relative to those satellites it would be
awesome for navigation
and by the way the way to do it
precisely is if we put super precise
clocks into space which would double
benefit us because then everyone would
have basically free access to precision
timing as well
and so the scientists argued for decades
that this would be valuable to humanity
but that's not why
it was funded because it seemed it
seemed too expensive at the time it
didn't people didn't fully understand
its value
until we ran into an issue
where we were in a cold war with the
with the ussr
and we had the capability to launch
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
they those intercontinental ballistic
missiles knew where they were because
they had inertial navigation systems in
them that were accurate for something
like 30 minutes
ditto for if we scrambled bombers and we
wanted to fly bombers and drop bombs
they would have inertial navigation
systems inside of them that were
accurate enough
but a problem came up
where what if russia shot first or what
if the ussr shot first and they targeted
our bombers and they targeted our icbm
silos we would have to be able to
mutually assure the destruction of
moscow
if that happened right we'd have to make
it too expensive for them to make that
decision
and so the way we do that is we have
something called trident missiles or
submarine launch ballistic missiles we
basically park nuclear missiles
hidden under the water
all around the world so that if anyone
tried to shoot first
it would hurt them
right we would we could guarantee that
that would hurt them even if we lost our
icbms even if we lost our bombers so
it's called the nuclear triad there's a
problem though technical problem the
technical problem is that submarine has
been under water for 30 days and the
inertial navigation system on it
is useless
so if we did get shot first and then we
decided to do a second strike to
mutually assure the destruction of
moscow and we launched that trident
missile and it breaks the surface how is
it going to know where it is
it has no idea where it is correct
missile has no idea
and so
what we realized is
man we need a giant constellation of
satellites so that anything anywhere in
the world at any time could know where
it is
particularly a trident submarine large
ballistic missile
and so that's eventually what caused us
to fund gps and then once we funded gps
and once we built this massive weapon
system right that was intended
explicitly to mutually assure the
destruction
of ussr
did we realize wow there's a lot of
other stuff that you could do with gps
this is great for civilization just like
the scientists kept on saying and then
in desert storm
the value of precision timing and
navigation was very clear and since then
especially once we turned off selective
availability and allowed everyone to
have precision navigation and timing
it's clear
but people often forget that gps is a
weapon system
it exists to mutually assure the
destruction of other countries right
there's a lot of weapons systems like we
have
that we have that do the same thing
right nuclear
hardin satellite communications right
pcpip the internet right the internet
exists so that we can survive we can
have c2 that survives a nuclear level
strike
sha
right
as in shaw 256
right as in designed by the nsa
these are these are these are systems
that are explicitly intended for the
defense
of the united states and so
um you know if we keep pulling that
thread eventually we get to
all of the critical enabling
technologies that go into bitcoin we get
tcp we get sha we get precision timing
and synchronization of nodes through gps
we get it written in c plus plus which
was uh you know something that an
american designed at bell laboratories
every single piece of bitcoin that
fundamentally matters is effectively
a piece of technology that was designed
to improve military scale defense
particularly against
the destruction of
nukes
and so
if you continue to pull that thread a
little bit further and a little bit
further
you can start to conceptualize
bitcoin as way more than just
money
bitcoin is and i know a lot of people on
twitter will be angry at me for saying
this bitcoin is a weapon system
just like gps is a weapon system
it is a weapon system designed
explicitly for self-defense
and it is extremely effective right it
it it is literally
nuclear resistant like every piece of it
was designed explicitly to be resistant
to nuclear strikes
so um that's you know that's pretty
interesting right there's some pro
there's probably some national strategic
opportunities with bitcoin that we could
take advantage of and that's kind of
what i want to explore okay so
two things one is recently naval ravicon
had a tweet where he said that bitcoin
is the second amendment which is very in
line with what you're talking about here
in terms of it is the defense mexico is
your right to bear arms right not
necessarily for offensive purposes but
also for defensive purposes and so when
you start to think about this the
network itself when you unpack the
players or the market participants if
you will there's the miners and the node
operators how do you think about uh the
relationship between those two as part
of this defense system for your
purchasing power or your economic value
and also how do you think about um kind
of them in relationship to if there was
some attack and didn't have to be a
nation-state attack could be a bad actor
it could be a whole bunch of different
things but unpack a little bit more
about this idea of like the network is
the defense system really there ends up
being kind of two core players right in
in terms of uh the node operation the
miners how do they fit into this in in
your kind of framework
yeah so i think a useful way to think
about it so this is where
the
the exploration of bitcoin becomes so
fascinating because to really fully
understand what it does and what value
it brings you have to think very big
and so if you this is
if you think about civilization you know
itself the role of governments the role
of
militaries
the role of currency bitcoin has a
little bit of everything
right so
so
you know you can you can abstract
governments
as effectively a trade mediation as a
service
right this is like it gets back to like
the champagne fairs in medieval uh
europe you would need a military you
need a military to preserve trade routes
right that's why you have navy
okay the navy will make sure that we
don't you know that our trade routes are
uninterrupted
you need a rule of law right to preserve
the the rules of the contracts to build
the contracts to preserve the rules of
the contracts and then you need a
a monetary
entity as well
bitcoin is all three it is a military it
is a rule of law and it is money
the miners the mining network is its
military
the nodes
right and the software is the rule of
law and the legislation and all the
voting
and
the least interesting part of it in my
opinion is
the money the satoshis right
that's like the thing that comes
last
what what makes bitcoin so special is
that
it has its own
military
that is literally as powerful
as nation-state
militaries and when you
when you think of that right so if you
think of that exact idea where it is
built in one of the things that i wrote
maybe two years ago at this point which
i took a ton of flak for at the time was
this idea that uh the money
historically on its rise to let's say uh
global reserve currency status or high
adoptability
ends up almost always being catapulted
to that position via
violent conflict in which one party ends
up being successful over another and
then they establish their money right so
you're one nation i'm another nation you
have the global reserve currency i show
up i conquer you now my money is the
global reserve currency so there's a
violent conflict that occurs and what i
wrote about was this idea that bitcoin
specifically
would be the first currency the first
store value to rise to global reserve
status without ever dropping a bomb
shooting a bullet needing soldiers guns
etc and the idea was in the analog world
the person who has the best offense is
the most powerful so if you have the
most firepower if you're the most
effective from an offensive standpoint
you are the most successful military in
terms of going and conquering but in the
cyber virtual what you know digital
world
if you have the best defense you're
actually the most powerful because all
you have to do is basically continue to
defend
24 7 365 without fail no matter what the
attack is and therefore people
begin to slowly adopt and realize that
this is the strongest thing and so
bitcoin's computing network is the
strongest computer network in the world
and therefore has the greatest defense
and if it has the greatest defense it
will continue to prove to be the
strongest the thing that people can put
the most trust in and over time it just
continues to kind of outlast everything
else
and so my thought process was like the
world changes when we go from like an
analog based world to a digital based
world and now it's not about offense
it's about defense which actually seems
to be somewhat in line with what you're
talking about here of the money and the
quote-unquote army being
one right they come together in a
package
yeah so
i can give you my thoughts and and for
the record all of these thoughts are my
thoughts these do not represent the
dod's thoughts
okay so
first of all yeah it is interesting the
correlation
between
the entity with the dominant military
tends to have the world reserve currency
right if you read that
it's also interesting that if you read
history
history
is is effectively a time partitioned
ledger
written by those who projected the most
kinetic power and and won
right
his history is written by the victors
history is written by the those who
won the power projection game right the
competition
okay
so
that's interesting the
the dis the distinction between offense
and defense is one that especially in
the space force is not very useful
we can um and i can kind of like we can
i'll illustrate that
if china were to put or let's say china
russia stand were to put a
nuclear-tipped hypersonic missile
into a parking orbit around the moon
is that an offensive action or is that a
defensive action
you're going to be more of an expert
than me i don't know what is it
right so
okay
let's ask another question if
the united states
blows up
that nuclear-tipped hypersonic
warhead in
in orbit around the moon is that an
offensive action or is that a defensive
action
yeah uh you hopefully you got the
answers man because i don't
yeah the the answer is
physics doesn't care right like the
answer is
physics is blind to the distinction
between offense and defense
and so
especially in the year 2021 where much
of everything we do is interconnected is
is cyber is
space
the distinction between what is an
offensive action and a defensive action
is gradually less meaningful
at the end of the day the first
principal's view of
any military action is
you're projecting
power right you are transferring joules
per second
right and yes
you know like whether or not you
interpret that as an offense and
defensive action is essentially what
side of the trade are you on china
russia stan is going to have a very
different opinion if we blow up their
nuclear warhead in lunar orbit than
america right so
in my like the way i look at it is
i i choose to look at things the way
that physics looks at things and physics
is blind to the distinction between
offense and defense
that being said
it is useful
to consider okay there may be different
types of ways that you can project
power
right if you
if i you know punch you in the face what
am i doing i am
displacing the mass of your head
over some distance
right which means i've
created energy right i've created joules
right and i've and the transfer of
joules over time is
power but that's not the only way to
create joules i could also
put a charge across
a resistor
right and you've
you've created electric energy
and the transfer of electric energy is
still joules per second there is
fundamentally no distinction between
kinetic power projection
and electric power projection it's just
how that power is generated that's the
difference
and so that gets really really
interesting when you start talking about
how
bitcoin works and why it's so similar to
the primary value delivered function of
militaries
it's because
this you know
all civilization all living creatures
obey the social consensus protocol
that those who project the most kinetic
power
in the most
clever way
earn the right to set the state and
chain of custody of limited resources no
one gets the option to like unsubscribe
from this social consensus protocol
right
those who project the most kinetic power
set the state and chain of custody
okay
that is true
not only for animals right you like if i
threw a juicy steak in between a pack of
wolves who gets the stake
whoever gets there first whoever's the
strongest
right so animals actually establish
their own pecking order based off of
their capability to project power
right humans are no different we're
animals too there's limited resources we
we it is an existential necessity for us
to establish a pecking order to achieve
consensus on the legitimate state and
chain of custody of all property
we do it through kinetic power
projection the cool thing about kinetic
power projection is it's a
permissionless protocol
i don't need the permission
of another country or another person if
i can project enough power in a clever
way right
that's how you establish a
permissionless control structure over
all
as you would say analog property
but what was really really fascinating
about bitcoin specifically
is that it takes this exact same power
projection gain
right
but instead of kinetically derived
joules it's electrically derived joules
and that
is really
really interesting it it works
effectively the same exact way as
militaries do what's the role of the
military the role of the military is to
project so much kinetic power that it's
too expensive not to cooperate with
whoever owns that military right that's
the that's the main deal the role of the
military is to countervail the control
authority of someone that has been
oppressive right so the reason why the
united states exists is because
people in north america
started feeling that the you know
monarchy was being oppressive to them so
they exercised their permissionless
control structure over property and here
we are now we identify as
americans so like that's important to
point out it's not just because you see
this all the time on twitter people are
bashing that like usd
you know is proof of war literally
everything is proof of war anthony
like if you identify as a citizen in a
country
that is because people
projected a bunch of kinetic power to
to create that rule of law like the
state of ownership of everything is as a
result of either kinetic proof of work
or
contractual legal proof which only
exists because
someone won a war to
to legitimize that
okay so how is bitcoin different bitcoin
bitcoin takes the exact same game
right that that all
animals have been playing
for
four billion years
but it transposes that game digitally so
instead of kinetic proof of work
you do
electric proof of work
those who project the most electric
power
and win the competition
earn the right
to set the state and chain of custody of
the underlying piece of property in this
case satoshi's
and if those entities which we would
call miners
ever become oppressive right if they
ever just start mining empty blocks and
not allowing people to
transact over the ledger
then the beautiful thing about
bitcoin is that it restores
the ability for all users to countervail
the control authority of those
oppressors through what projection of
power and in bitcoin denominated terms
it always gets easier to project more
power it's never been cheaper to mine
right it's cheaper to mine now with an
s19 than it is to mine with you know
your usb miners from a while ago in
bitcoin denominated terms which means
it's always getting easier and easier
for users to countervail the control
authority of oppressors if they emerge
and so
that's interesting because then
what effectively is the primary value
delivered function of bitcoin is not to
create a piece of digital property that
part to me is boring
the part that is interesting to me is
you have restored a permissionless
control structure
over any a property
using the exact same way like the exact
same
mechanism as warfare
and you've done so after civilization
has
effectively
stalemated itself with nuclear power the
problem with nuclear weapons is it's too
expensive
to
use them right so we have lost
civilization has lost their ability
uh to have permissionless control
structure over property right if
does that make sense like it makes sense
yeah we risk nuclear annihilation
correct to to use this
um to use this power projection protocol
now so that that's bad by the way it's
not the first time it happens happens
all the time in nature
so
nature animals will actually grow
random power projection mechanisms out
of their foreheads so that they can
continue to play the game and establish
pecking order and to achieve consensus
on the legitimate state and chain of
custody of resources like
territory right we call them antlers
right we call them you know look at bugs
with their weird horns on the top right
they evolved a way to continue the power
projection again but do so
in a in a way that won't
threaten the species right like we're
not going to kill each other
anymore we're just going to awkwardly
clash our antlers together and then
that's how we're going to decide who
gets to own what
and so
this sounds ridiculous i know
but i keep telling people bitcoin are
human antlers
we have
re-established a way
to achieve a permissionless control
structure over property which is needed
to defend against
oppression
and
but still maintain
fairness right still maintain the
ability to achieve consensus on the
legitimate state and chain of custody of
a property
and so that's pretty cool we should
probably monetize that
right
and like people are like well you know
there's no way bitcoin would ever
um
you know end war it's like no i'm not
saying it would end war right like
obviously kinetic power projection would
still be
necessary
for all forms of physical property that
people value right like there's
low probability that i'm going to stop
valuing water that i'm going to stop
valuing
you know land
that i'm going to stop valuing contracts
that i'm going to stop valuing oxygen
but no one says we have to monetize
those things what if the cool thing
about
money is it can take any shape it wants
it's a shape-shifting thing
and so if you transpose money
into a digital commodity
and re-establish a power projection
permissionless control structure over it
then what you've effectively done
and i know this is wacko
but what you have effectively done
is digitally transformed
warfare itself from a kinetic power
projection game into an electric power
projection game and so in so far as we
fight each other
to defend against money
we don't need to and the
last thing i'll say before
opening it for comments is this
and this is why i drew that
picture because we have a picture we
have the picture here that uh that we're
gonna show everyone
okay so
the thing i wrote this in class i was
not paying attention to class
um the thing that bothers me about like
these esg accusations against bitcoin is
like they fundamentally misunderstand
what the point
of bitcoin is right they fundamentally
misunderstand what the point of all that
energy or all that power projection is
the point of projecting that much power
is to make it too expensive
to attack
the the ledger right like to make it too
expensive to be uncooperative with the
people who who use bitcoin
this is exactly what the military does
right every single
the power of every single
bomb the power of every single bullet
the power of every single engine behind
every single plane or ship or sub or
truck or tank the power of every
heartbeat of every service member
of every military in the world
is measured in watts
and those watts are spent
explicitly
to protect and defend resources
up until bitcoin
to protect and defend monetary resources
and to say that bitcoin is a waste of
energy
is effectively the same as saying
your military is a waste of energy it's
a waste of energy to have a standing
military to protect our rule of law or
whatever we're trying to protect
like yeah it's inefficient to sail a
bunch of carrier battle groups through
the ocean
right you know it's more inefficient
anthony than sailing a bunch of carrier
battle groups or testing about a bunch
of nuclear missiles all the time
being invaded
being conquered
that's pretty inefficient and if you
want to learn what happens to people who
decide not to build a standing military
read history history is literally just
you know a story of all the countries
that decided that it was too inefficient
to have a standing military
right
and so it's like
oh it you know bitcoin's bad because it
projects too much power it's like saying
you know dollar for dollar i wish my
military projected less power so if you
don't understand the point
of bitcoin the point of bitcoin is to
defend the network to defend every user
that volunteers
to make that underlying piece of
property their form of money
and so when we look at this image that
you have drawn here what's so
fascinating to me is that you are taking
a lot of these ideas which uh i think
are one very nuanced but two very um
kind of uh deep intellectually and you
literally put it on one piece of paper
right which is very hard for a lot of
people uh to uh to do is to take these
complex ideas and explain them simply
but what i think is uh probably the most
important part of this entire uh
thing that you've drawn here is that
there's a dotted line across the middle
and on top of that dotted line you have
an arrow pointing up and you say that
the assets such as land and real estate
gold oil equities etc are all defended
with military and rule of law
and then below the dotted line you have
a arrow down that says bitcoin is
protected and defended with electricity
and code and so is the argument here
that ultimately the protection via
electricity and code is not only
superior from an uh effectiveness
standpoint but also it is uh superior
from efficiency standpoint as well is
that a fair uh way to kind of think
about this
yeah so like let's just do a thought
experiment
i would love to do a thought experiment
with you go ahead
how many bombs would it take
to blow up the internet
a lot
yeah
i don't know i thought about it how many
it would probably take a lot of bombs
right like to stop bitcoin you would
have to hunt down every miner
forever
right and maintain that and so
that's like really difficult
um to do it is it is and
so like the efficiency of mining is
awesome
you
but it but still like
even efficiency so this is the trap this
is a trap that people do with like esg
they'll say
bitcoin uses too much energy it could be
more resourceful or it could be more
renewable energy right
and then you respond with okay well it's
getting more renewable and it's not that
bad it's like pretty efficient for the
amount of defense
but the problem is the esg
argument is essentially an ethical
argument
correct
right it's not a rational argument it's
an ethical argument and so that bothers
me because if you want to make an
ethical argument that bitcoin is a waste
of energy
then you have to do an apples and apples
comparison
to
the resources that are spent to defend
legacy property
and the resources that are spent to
defend legacy property
is human bloodshed
right like that's why
the rule of law is the rule of law
that's why
we can say
we own this land not another nation
right
the state and chain of custody of all
legacy monetary property
is written in blood
right and so
so you just have to be careful like
yes i agree that bitcoin is super a
super efficient way to defend monetary
property but they're not really people
aren't really arguing about efficiency
they're they're making an ethical case
and so if you want to play the ethical
game then let's play that game right
but that being said yeah it's like way
off like way efficient
to use bitcoin to defend your property
in this case what you would choose to
serve as money as it would be
to
use an entire military
but also
it's better to pay an electric bill than
it is
to
pay a blood bill if that makes sense uh
absolutely i've got one more question
than my brother so i got questions for
you uh my question is when you think of
this idea of uh kind of electricity uh
electrical uh protection right whether
it's offense defense whatever it is that
there's an electrical power that goes
into this and that is the uh the network
how do you think about that being in the
hands of individuals whether they're in
the united states or elsewhere right and
kind of this idea of they can use that
protection against the oppressive
government or uh against any sort of
overreaching monetary policy that steals
uh purchasing power or anything like
that versus it being in the hands of
corporations financial institutions or
even nation states themselves right like
to me one of the most interesting
aspects of bitcoin is that it doesn't
matter who you are right if you go all
the way up to uh michael saylor and
microstrategy holding bitcoin he is no
different than you holding bitcoin me
holding bitcoin or somebody in india
somewhere in an african country or
somebody on uh uh you know south
american country right just everyone is
the same in terms of holding that
bitcoin but
when you start to talk about this as a
kind of a military wrapped into a
monetary
asset
i do think that people say okay well
what happens when the nation states
actually start to buy bitcoin we've seen
el salvador now start to do this so like
do you have any thoughts there in terms
of bitcoin in different people's hands
if that changes your analysis or uh are
we overthinking it in some way
i guess first of all it's in everyone's
best interest
to defend themselves
okay so
like if you create a pristine
self-defense architecture
you can bet that like every type of
person
or organization regardless of what their
interests are would benefit from
having a pristine self-defense network
correct
what what's super interesting about
bitcoin is
it creates
a
kind of game theory
stability point a shelling point
that i am calling in my thesis mutually
assured preservation
it's to distinguish it from
the shelling point that we get with
kinetic proof of work which is mutually
assured
destruction
so it the
the way we achieve stability right now
through kinetic proof of work is to
basically
hold a knife to each other's throats and
say don't do anything bad
right that's how we achieve stability
with bitcoin
everything that a nation does to
increase the hash rate is beneficial to
everyone else assuming they don't
51 attack the network
so
you were actually like by quote
projecting more electric power
in bitcoin you are actually
mutually assuring the preservation of
the security of your opponent
and so this gets really interesting
because like
maybe instead of
fighting you just let them
improve the hash rate let them improve
the security so long as it doesn't 51
percent attack the network
or like
you know
if everyone's using the same currency
then the productivity of your opponent
means real world gains for you too
right if and so that's the beautiful
thing about bitcoin is it creates
frenemies
right it doesn't matter who you are
if you use bitcoin you are
you are benefiting each other mutually
if and so like
by the way
if you buy a bunch of bitcoin first and
front run everyone else
then
they
their productivity benefits you
disproportionately more
so like
it'd probably be a good idea to buy it
to buy a lot of it right like you see
you know you see these people talking
about like
you know bitcoin will be it represents a
huge capital flight risk
okay how do you fix that buy it before
they do and recapture the capital
right
like
there's a whole lot there are very few
scenarios
where
buying bitcoin doesn't solve the
strategic threat
if that makes sense
i i think that this idea of um
moving from a zero-sum to a positive
some world is very important because
ultimately what you are doing is you are
simply saying that humans are going to
continue to be humans they're going to
continue to look after their best
self-interest
they're going to look for
the ability to protect themselves
and in doing so as they adopt the
protection that protection then they are
incentivized to
increase its efficiency its
effectiveness its strength etc and in by
increasing their ability to protect
themselves they are inherently
protecting you as well
this is a concept that uh historically
has not been afforded to folks and so it
takes a while to break down kind of the
old mental framework and
replace it
with this new idea of in a positive sum
world
human incentives take over
and everyone ends up adopting the asset
that can protect themselves and as they
do that they actually protect everybody
else which means that the need for
conflict is drastically reduced because
ultimately uh as protected as you are so
is your enemy and therefore if you have
confidence in your own protection system
you therefore should have doubt in your
offensive capabilities of violating
their protection as well right
yeah so
first of all like i wouldn't say that
humans would will continue to be humans
i would say that animals will continue
to be animals true right like literally
all living creatures as an existential
necessity must fight over limited
resources the biggest bloodbath was four
billion years ago between
single cellular organisms right this is
this is a
this is a social consensus protocol over
resources that no one gets to
unsubscribe to
if you're unless your heart doesn't
bleed if it gets hit by a bullet you
tacitly comply to this social consensus
protocol
and so
so that was the first first point i made
but there's nothing that says it has to
be a kinetic
power projection protocol it could be
electric cool thing about electric is no
one has to bleed
right and and another thing too which is
super fascinating is with kinetic power
projection
you
scale you basically destroy
infrastructure right the end of the war
is
rubble right infrastructure is destroyed
as you scale kinetic power projection
higher and higher and higher to the
point where you get atomic level
like horrors
with electric power projection
the end gain is more infrastructure
cheaper energy for everybody
right so like the end of a hash war is
free energy and abundance for everybody
and you you achieve that
using literally the same physics it is
the same physics
why don't we play that game over
monetary property that sounds like a
good idea
correct joe and john what questions do
you guys have
hey jason thanks for doing this uh my
question would just be i want to hear
like i was thinking to myself you were
saying some wild stories earlier about
uh
not only the gps and everything like
that but
my i'm curious about what is the
craziest like thing about space that
people have no idea about
um
i know you got something
yeah i mean there's a lot like when you
look when you look up into the sky and
see stars you're looking down
into the universe
all right that was pretty good
explain
[Laughter]
when when you look at
like a star you're looking at the past
like billion
like very many years ago
when you
uh
it's it's pretty awesome space is pretty
cool
but yeah so like you know uh you know
look down
um
when you look into the sky you're mostly
just looking down into the milky way and
pretty much all you can see is a couple
of local stars
that's it
that's crazy so yeah that was even
better than i expected
john what questions you got jason what's
up thank you for your service first of
all you represent space force well
how many people from space force have
you talked you're the first one i think
i want to sign up tomorrow
thank you
jason you could take that clip and you
could send it to your boss and then he's
like look i should do more of these
right we're out here recruiting
yeah so
my question is most people don't think
about bitcoin in the manner that you
thought about they really just think
about price what are your thoughts
around the price of bitcoin
it hasn't changed it's been as far as i
know
100 million satoshi's
that's the best answer i've ever heard
and what's cool about
what's cool about satoshi's is like
what used to cost me a hundred thousand
satoshis to buy now cost me 20 000
satoshi's to buy
that's pretty sweet
and when you think about that idea
is the end game here
that everything gets priced in satoshis
because ultimately all other forms of
value don't have the protection
of that kind of electrical uh power
production and therefore naturally more
and more and more people who have
monetary value want to protect it with
the most superior form of protection and
therefore that economic value they
demonetize other assets and it flows
into the most protection that they can
find
there's three functions of money right
three big ones
store value medium of exchange
unit of account correct
right now there's a whole bunch of
trauma
over what's going to be the next medium
of exchange
i don't really care
that's not really important to me store
of value
is important to me but the holy grail
is unit of account how do you measure
value itself how do you perceive
value itself
if you measure and perceive value in
satoshis
then mathematically speaking by
definition
the value of everything
is
well sorry the
price of everything is decreasing
relatively relative to satoshi's
and so
the
like
so
if you want
to
essentially
you want to own the value token if you
own the token which denominates value
itself
then you literally own everything right
so like like mathematically speaking so
for example
it's like super funny when people are
like well look at the price of ethereum
right
uh the bitcoin denominated cost of
ethereum is
increasing or decreasing like take take
your pick
okay right first of all you made that
conversion using dollars right so you
took the dollar denominated cost of
ethereum and you divided it by the
dollar denominated cost of bitcoin
but the more important point is
you just denominated the value of your
ethereum in bitcoin you have tacitly
acknowledged that bitcoin is a good unit
of account
to measure the quote value of your
bitcoin and so or sorry to measure the
value of your ethereum
so what happens when everybody starts
thinking that way when everyone says
you know if they want to know what the
real value of their thing is they ask
themselves how many bitcoin could i
convert it to
the whole your whole perception of
everything changes
completely
and you you enter this world where like
you finally actually have a perfect
signal on what value is because no one's
messing with the purchasing power of
your denominator
it's really powerful stuff and so
the single most important question to
ask yourself is a hundred and hundred
years
into the future
you know as we progress into the future
what are people most likely going to use
as their unit of account are they going
to use the thing that that is
whose purchasing power is constantly
changing
or
are they going to use the thing that
stays fixed
or are they going to use this thing that
stays fixed and has the most powerful
defense infrastructure
around it right they
i'll i'll give you a spoiler it's
already bitcoin
people are already comparing the value
of their crypto in so far as the number
of bitcoin it converts to they use
dollars to make that conversion but
eventually that might not be true
and so if you want to front run
everybody
buy bitcoin
so i have two questions to finish up
with the first one uh
is a little bit more fun
which is i saw somebody ask
what do they call members of the space
force the army their soldiers etc what
are members of the space force called
we're called guardians guardians okay
yeah we there was a bunch of like
different names it could have been
sentinel it could have been a couple
other things and we kind of voted on
they actually asked us to vote on what
we want to be called and so right now
we're called guardians
i feel like that is very fitting for you
uh the the second question that i have
uh is
your background you have uh i think
screen savers up you've got a computing
device
in the corner
explain a little bit as to what's going
on here because this also is very
fitting for this conversation
um
it's a computer
so in the uh so i used to be the
director of operations for the second
space launch squadron out at vandenberg
space force base which is the base that
launches all of our satellites into
polar orbits okay
and what's cool about being on like the
ops floor of
a launch control room is you have these
huge screens
and the reason why is because you need
to see as much data as possible without
having to like
to lower a tab to like minimize a tab on
your on your screen
and so after spending many hours in
control rooms
with the luxury of never having to to
ever minimize a tab i was like well okay
why don't i apply that to my home
command control station and so i just
found a bunch of cheapo monitors
and uh
put them together and now i can't
remember the last time i've lowered a
tab
amazing um my last comment is uh there
are three times
in the
five or six years that i've been doing
this now where i've had a conversation
with somebody and when we end the
conversation i say to myself
i am going to immediately go buy more
bitcoin
the first time was when i talked to a
gentleman named murad mahabdev uh he
essentially laid out an argument for the
legacy financial assets being
demonetized uh over time flowing that
economic value into bitcoin uh and doing
some simple back of the napkin math said
you know 10 million dollar bitcoin price
in u.s dollar terms not necessarily
because uh you think you're a trader but
more so understanding kind of macro
capital flows monetization of assets
demonetization uh trusting those assets
et cetera so very similar to the
conversation we're having now
second one was when michael saylor uh
and i spoke uh when he for the first
time talked about putting bitcoin on his
balance sheet and he explained to me the
logic that he had uh both from an
understanding of bitcoin uh but also
from an economic standpoint of
protecting his balance sheet and this
idea of uh in your words kind of using
that electrical power production to
protect his uh his balance sheet
the third time's today
because i don't think i've ever heard
somebody describe uh bitcoin as having
kind of this wrapped value of both the
money
with a
stand-in army that is neither offensive
or defensive uh but has the ability to
use that electrical power production and
when you think of it in terms of the
electrical power production being the
single greatest
kind of protection that you can provide
to a monetary asset i think it becomes
pretty clear that other assets over time
and again you know what that time frame
is is up for debate uh people will lose
trust and frankly lose appetite either
from an ethical standpoint or
kind of a rational standpoint
in wanting bloodshed to protect that
monetary premium or those monetary
assets
and so if i'm given the choice between
uh send you know young men and women to
war
or
use electrical power production to
protect my assets
i think most people over time decide
well that electrical thing sounds pretty
damn good right sounds like uh that's
more humane sounds like it's more
effective it's more efficient
and i think more importantly uh
it shows a path to a positive sum world
where
when you begin to understand the
importance of that
and the impact of that then ultimately i
think it falls back to this comment that
i always make which is the rise and
adoption of bitcoin in my personal
opinion will do more good
for the world then all philanthropy
combined
and when you measure it in terms of
economic impact maybe that's true maybe
that's not but when you measure it in
terms of the avoidance of conflict or
the protection of purchasing power and
the ability to close wealth inequality
gaps from a first principle standpoint
etc
just very very compelling so i
appreciate taking the time to come and
talk about this i'm going to do my
absolute best to wrangle you into coming
back as many times as you will let me uh
wrangle you into doing this because i
think people can learn a lot from you uh
but i'll ask john and joe if you guys
had any uh last comments before uh we
let jason go jason i got one additional
question for you what is a must-read
book from you what's your favorite book
i used to tell people
uh
i used to give people recommendations
about taleb but i don't do that anymore
that's the best answer all day
so um
probably sapiens
the great one
awesome man where can we send people uh
i've dropped your uh twitter account
into the chat uh do you want us to send
people to linkedin anywhere else that uh
we should send folks to uh to find you
on the internet
yeah just my linkedin and my twitter i
use both of those
to essentially test ideas
for for the research i'm doing and to be
fully transparent about everything that
i'm doing
some of my takes are garbage and i
appreciate the feedback that i get
particularly from twitter when those
ticks are garbage um but i can't express
enough how thankful i am for just the
fantastic arguments the fantastic
support that i get from everyone i
really appreciate it and also pomp that
was really nice of what you said earlier
so thank you
i i meant every word of it uh there's
very few people after having done this
for so long that i uh
know from the first time the first time
you and i are talking uh verbally um
that i just know one you're gonna be a
star
two uh it would be in the best interest
of every single person that is already
protecting their monetary assets with
that electrical power production to make
sure that we fill your calendar with as
many podcasts television appearances
blog posts tweets etc as possible
because i think you have a message that
a lot of people can benefit from so i
appreciate you coming on here and
talking about it and uh i'm gonna go
look at my calendar after i buy some
bitcoin and figure out when i can bring
you back
cool thanks joe thanks john thanks bob
appreciate it awesome thank you so much
take care later